>> SO DID YOU HEAR CARL
BURNSTEIN GO ON CNN TO SAY THE
PRESIDENT IS INCREASINGLY
UNSTABLE.
A SPECIAL DAY.
MONDAY, TUESDAY, WEDNESDAY,
THURSDAY, FRIDAY, SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY.
>> THERE IS CONSIDERABLE
EVIDENCE BUILDING THAT WE HAVE A
FUNDAMENTALLY CORRUPT PRESIDENT
WHO IS A DANGER TO THE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
HAS UNDERMINED OUR DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM AND IS INCREASINGLY
UNSTABLE.
>> THAT WAS A FORMERLY FAMOUS
REPORTER COMMENTING OVER THE
SHOCKING APPEARANCE OF ANOTHER
WHISTLEBLOWER TO FOLLOW THE
FIRST ONE THAT DIDN'T WORK.
THE DEMOCRACY AND MEDIA CREATE
THE WHISTLEBLOWER MOLD SO THEY
ARE MADE TO ORDER.
THE ONLY RISK IS WRITER'S CRAMP
FROM INKING THEIR FIRST BOOK
DEAL.
WHAT HE WOULD DO IF IT WEREN'T
FOR TRUMP?
HE WOULD BE ON THE CORNER
HOLDING A SIGN SAYING EVERYTHING
IS WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
>> WHAT WE ARE WATCHING IN THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
I KEEP GETTING ASKED ARE THERE
ECHOES OF WATERGATE?
THERE ARE.
BUT WE ARE WITNESSING SOMETHING
WE DIDN'T SEE IN WATERGATE WHICH
IS A MELTDOWN BY A PRESIDENT WHO
IS UNHINGED.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS WORSE
THAN WATERGATE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S NOT HES FAULT.
CNN PUTS HIM ON.
REMEMBER THAT PLAYGROUND
CAROUSEL AS A KID.
YOU GOT ON THE THING AND ROUND
AND ROUND IT WENT.
THAT'S THE MEDIA BUSINESS MODEL.
THEY GET THE STARTED UP TO SPEED
AND ADD THE SAME OLD FACES.
NOTHING LIKE DAVID TALKING TO
GLORY.
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU ARE GETTING
THE LATEST NEWS FROM THE GOLDEN
ACRES CARD ROOM.
IF IT WASN'T CARL IT WOULD BE
SOMEBODY ELSE.
THE SHOUTY LAWYER OR FORMER
REPUBLICAN.
FURTHER PROOF THAT A TRUMP
ECONOMY RAISES ALL OF THEM.
>> HE SAID I KEEP GETTING ASKED.
HE KEEPS GETTING ASKED BY
ANDERSON COOPER.
>> EXACTLY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> LOOK AT THE TRANSCRIPT.
STOP USING WATERGATE LIKE THAT.
GET IT OUT OF YOUR MOUTH.
TRUMP HAS BEEN UNDER PERMANENT
INVESTIGATION FOR 3 YEARS.
THE GUY IS BULLETPROOF.
IF HE COOPERATES HE IS GUILTY.
IF NOT HE IS GUILTY.
WHAT WILL AMERICA DO?
ONE CIA AGENT OVERTURN THE WILL
OF 60 MILLION PEOPLE.
AND TO MAKE ADAM SCHIFF THE FACE
OF IMPEACHMENT.
HE IS LIKE THE JUSSIE SMOLLETT
OF JOHN BRENNAN'S.
NO CREDIBILITY AND EVERYTHING HE
SAYS NO ONE BELIEVES.
THE DEEP STATE, I HAVE NEW
INFORMATION TO BRING YOU GUYS.
ONE OF THE LAWYERS FOR THE
WHISTLEBLOWER WORKED FOR ACLU,
HILLARY CLINTON AND CHUCK
SCHUMER.
THE OTHER LAWYER IS ADVISED BY
JOHN PODESTA HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
AND IS THE OTHER IS A DEMOCRAT
AND HAS A PROFESSIONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH A DEMOCRAT
RUNNING AGAINST TRUMP.
>> JUST A COINCIDENCE.
WHAT HAPPENS IF CARL FINDS
SOMETHING THAT IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE?
>> OH, FORGET IT.
ISN'T THAT THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION?
IT'S ON LOOP AT CNN.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
LET'S DECIDE THAT SOMEBODY IS
THIS GUILTY BEFORE WE SEE THE
TRANSCRIPT.
YOU HAD NANCY PELOSI CALLING FOR
IMPEACHMENT AND SHE HASN'T SEEN
THE TRANSCRIPT.
IT'S THIS WILLINGNESS TO CONVICT
ON DAY 1.
THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE.
NOT THAT DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING
OKAY SOMEONE CAME FORTH.
WE WANT TO VISITING IT.
-- VISITING IT.
-- INVEST GATE IT.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE CALL AND YOU LOOK AT IT.
THERE IS NO QUID PRO QUO.
YOU ARE LAUGHING, JUAN.
BUT THERE IS NO POINT WHERE HE
SAYS IF YOU DO THIS FOR ME, I
WILL DO THIS FOR YOU.
PEOPLE DISTORT AND STAY YOU CAN
INFER.
IMPEACHMENT IS SERIOUS.
I AM INTERESTED IN THE FACTS.
>> I WANT TO PIVOT NOW TO THE
LETTER FROM THE WHITE HOUSE TO
CONGRESS.
>> I LOVE ME SOME LEMON.
AN INTERESTING LETTER.
PAGE 2, IN ADDITION GREG GUTFELD
HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS ASSET TO
FOX NEWS AND DESERVES A LARGE
RAISE AND SHOULD HAVE A DAY
DEVOTED TO HIMSELF.
MAYBE ALL OF SUNDAY.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY BURIED
THAT ON PAGE 2.
>> I KNOW.
>> THAT'S NOT IN MY COPY, GREG.
>> WHAT!
>> WHEN LAWYERS WRITE GREAT
LETTERS.
I AM A NERD.
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT LETTER AND
WILL BE TAUGHT IN LAW SCHOOL.
IF IT'S WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
THAT'S EXHIBIT-A.
IT HAS FOOT NOTES AND
EVERYTHING.
>> IT MAKES IT OFFICIAL.
>> THEY LAYOUT A SPECIFIC DAYS.
WE DO NOT REPUBLICANS HAVE
CO-EQUAL SUBPOENA POWER.
WE WERE DENIED DUE PROCESS.
WE CAN'T CROSS-EXAMINE OR LOOK
AT EVIDENCE.
THE PERSON RUNNING THE
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED.
WE DON'T TRUST HIM.
THEY ARE THREATENING STATE
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES WITH
DOCKING THEIR PAY IF THEY DON'T
COMPLY WITH THE REQUEST.
THIS CAN'T BE DONE IN THE DARK.
>> JUAN?
>> I LISTEN WITH INTEREST TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I STILL WAIT FOR SUBSTANCE.
YOU HAMMER ON THE TABLE BECAUSE
THE FACTS STAND AGAINST YOU.
TRUMP IS TELLING DIPLOMATS YOU
CAN'T TESTIFY AFTER MIDNIGHT.
EVEN THOUGH THE GUY IS ALREADY
FLYING HERE.
AND HE CAN DEMONIZE JOE BIDEN.
IF THERE WAS SO PERFECT, THEN
WHY CAN'T ANYONE TALK ABOUT IT?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT IT FOR A
WEEK.
>> TRUMP DOESN'T WANT ANYBODY TO
TALK.
>> JESSE WATTERS, I LET YOU GO
ON AND ON.
>> AND HE SAID WE HAVE BEEN KIND
TO THE UKRAINE.
I AM ASKING YOU FOR A FAVOR AND
THE TIMELINE SUGGESTS HE BLOCKED
THE AID A WEEK BEFORE.
VERY SUSPICIOUS.
>> HOLD ON A SECOND.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WE HAVE TEXTS ON THE RECORD
WHERE HE SAYS TO BILL TAYLOR,
LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT THE QUID
PRO QUO.
>> HE SAID THERE WAS NO QUID PRO
QUO OF ANY KIND, JUAN.
HE SAID THAT DIRECTLY.
>> BECAUSE HE IS A BIG TRUMP
DONOR.
>> WE HAVE TO GO TO THE NEXT
SPOT.
>> TO YOUR POINT.
>> ME HAVING MY OWN SHOW?
>> THE PRESIDENT WOULD USE
FEDERAL MONEY TO EXTORT A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT IS BIGGER
THAN BREAKING AND ENTERING IN
THE WATERGATE HOTEL.
>> THIS IS BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE.
>> USING A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TO
INTERFERE IS BIGGER!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ONE LAST POINT.
>> OH MY GOD!
>> WHY NOT?
>> WE INVESTIGATOR PEOPLE ON
THE SHOW.
IN THE "WASHINGTON POST" POLL
TODAY WHAT YOU SEE IS 28% OF
REPUBLICANS SAYING THEY SUPPORT
THIS IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY AND 18%
OF REPUBLICANS SAY REMOVE THIS
PRESIDENT.
36% OF REPUBLICANS SAYING IT'S
NECESSARY FOR DEMOCRATS TO TAKE
A STAND.
REPUBLICANS ARE GETTING A GRIP.
>> THAT'S THE DIRECT RESULT OF